and look at least back home in
Massachusetts there are a lot of
employers who really would like to have
the extra help to have the extra workers
Liz Warren uh 1
1024th Native American Liz Warren who
said she was a Native American so she
could get a job at Harvard which is the
most like perfect progressive thing you
could ever do uh she went on quote
unquote comedian Steven colar show last
night to explain that she's not happy
about this border deal and you might
find that interesting why wouldn't
someone on the left be happy with the
Border deal well it's not doing enough
for the illegal immigrants and migrants
in fact it's actually the bill the
Republicans are probably couldn't get
under other circumstances because it
doesn't have comprehensive immigration
reform it has border security well and
so here's the thing it's got some really
good pieces in it's got more resources
for the border which is good it's got in
it for example accelerated it's got work
permits in it so people who are here who
are trying to get asyl
actually would be allowed legally to go
get jobs and that means yeah pay
taxes they could they could move out of
shelters they could pay taxes and look
at least back home in Massachusetts
they're a lot of employers who really
would like to have the extra help to
have the extra workers so there's some
good things in here I also want to say
there's some things that are really
missing here you remember back during Co
that one of the things we all talked
about were the essential workers who
kept us all going there was a lot of
undocumented workers and I worked on a
bill with a lot of other people to say
let's create a path to citizenship for
these undocumented workers let's not I
don't want to bang a pan to say thank
you I actually want to say you have
helped save this nation you kept our
food supply going you kept our Medical
Care going you kept our trash pickup
going we are grateful and we will show
we are grateful by creating the path to
citizenship interesting nothing about
actually having a border defending our
border who are these people and
everything else by the way Elizabeth
Warren's worth around 60 million dollars
I don't know how many people she's
giving that money to so that they can go
you know you know buy homes and things
like that it's like share lady you're a
socialist share share but again this is
what they are doing instead of ever
talking about what would be good for
Americans it's always what's good for
those oh we'll give them a pathway to
citizenship we'll get them out of the
shelters it's like wait one thing at
Time Lady how about have a border first
how about we figure out who these people
are and everything else and also Co was
a complete farce I don't know if she
knows that maybe we should could we can
we send her an email on that we can get
that to her office and and the real
farce related to co of course was that
they told some of us that we are
non-essential and what is their
implication we needed we just needed
these illegals to be here to keep the
country going dur like it's all just
nonsense and it's done on a completely
farsal quote unquote comedy
show